researchers have found a new source cove  to variant which is named as  b1.640.2 or the ihu variant this was  found in france and so far 12th cases  has been discovered and a person who is  returning from cameron which is an  african country was reported to be  positive with this variant  there are many variants worldwide right  now omicron is a dominating variant ihu  has 46 mutation and 37 deletions now  doctors are questioning is it more  dangerous than omicron or delta variant  so we really don't know that  we also don't know whether it is more  transmissible or not probably not  because otherwise the world is populated  by ihu and not omicron anyway the open  question so far are will vaccination  work against this ihu variant is ihu  riskier than delta or whether ih2  variant can lead to a fourth wave in  india so subscribe for more information